alors donc plus loin sur le cac
evergreen avec marc andré flageul qui
gestionnaire de portefeuille chez
presima gestionnaires spécialisés en
immobilier sur les marchés boursiers
bonsoir
j'ai fait le job vous connaissez bien le
marché asiatique qui est evergrey and we
are one en fait une compagnie qui a été
fondée dans les années 90 et qui a
vraiment commencé à prendre une
expansion très importante dans 2014
c'est une compagnie qui est maintenant
aujourd'hui un des trois plus importants
développeurs immobiliers de chine avec
une implication dans plus de 1300 projet
immobilier à travers 280 en chine on
parle d'un chiffre d'affaires l'an
dernier en 2020 200 milliards de dollars
canadiens donc des ventes sont
extrêmement importants deux cent mille
employés donc vraiment un géant et qui a
la particularité et on va certainement
parler d'être très endettés donc d'abord
un fardeau de dette d'environ 4 5
milliards de dollars canadiens alors
vous allez nous expliquer ce qui se
passe d'abord je veux juste montrer le
graphique de la dégringolade de l'action
de 80% au cours de la dernière année ou
même depuis le début de l'année alors
comment expliquent les difficultés de
cette entreprise oui on est resté tout à
fait par son son endettement et surtout
un changement d'attitude du gouvernement
chinois vers la fin de l'année dernière
où le gouvernement essentiellement a mis
en place une politique de migros et
cette ligne rouge bien faire en sorte
que le levier ou de la dette que peuvent
prendre les développeurs immobiliers est
limité donc on se retrouve pour et
regret une situation où on dépasse cette
limite là et en plus de gouvernements
est venu mettre certaines limites de
certaines contraintes sur le crédit
bancaire en chine donc ce que les gens
peuvent emprunter le coût d'emprunt ce
qui a eu pour effet de ralentir la des
unités résidentielles évidemment une
compagnie aussi endetté qu'evergrande
qui a besoin de vendre des unités s'y
rendre en moins c'est exercer ses
problèmes ça devient plus important et
donc qu'on approche d'une situation où
l'entreprise ne pourrait plus finalement
respecter ses obligations financières
quel serait l'effet de la chute de ce
géant de l'économie chinoise si je me
trompe à 90% des gens en chine
détiennent leur propriété c'est un c'est
effectivement le cas c'est un secteur
extrêmement important de l'économie
chinoise et c'est probablement pour ça
qu'on en parle autant aujourd'hui c'est
si on prend les secteurs directs et
indirects qui lie à l'immobilisme
environ 25% du pib donc la chute d'un
d'un géant comme ça pourrait avoir un
impact significatif sur l'économie est
ce que ça entraîne comme effet domino en
fait c'est que si les les créanciers de
vergoignan de +35 chine à l'heure
actuelle s'offre d'une restructuration
désordonnée donc perdre davantage de
leurs billes ils vont en plus réticents
à prêter à d'autres développeurs
immobiliers qui sont dans certains cas
tout aussi endetté donc une espèce
d'effet domino le crédit peut devenir
plus difficile pour l'ensemble du
secteur et ça c'est évidemment ça
devient aussi un élément qui minent la
confiance des acheteurs qui pourraient
éventuellement faire baisser les prix
des résidentiels et et comme vous le
dites 90 % des gens sont son détenteur
donc c'est une bonne partie de leur la
banque qui est qu'il y ait gagné ses
actifs effet domino sur l'économie
mondiale
oui tout à fait c'est possible c'est
compte tenu que si on regarde la demande
pour les matières premières rend chez
une bonne portion est liée à
excepté de construction dans le secteur
résidentiel donc c'est possible que au
niveau économique mondiale certains pays
qui importent ou qui exporte plutôt des
matières premières vers la chine
pourrait également souffrir d'effets
collatéraux
en même temps chez flagelle la banque
centrale intervient elle a augmenté son
injection de liquidités à court terme
d'un système bancaire et on imagine que
le gouvernement chinois ne laisserait
pas tomber cette entreprise non en fait
c'est une question très intéressante à
l'heure actuelle je pense que le
scénario principal est ce que le marché
boursier reflète
pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui et de
scénarios dans la machine - intervenir
mais chinois est en ce moment sur une
espèce de ligne difficile à maintenir
parce que depuis le début de l'année
comme comme vous savez même un peu le
frein sur certaines industries qui ont
enrichi plusieurs individus on n'a qu'à
penser à l'ibpt à bâle qui est illicite
et aux états unis ou même plus récemment
ou au casino aux opérateurs de casino
dans le territoire de macao donc le
gouvernement joue avec une ligne qui est
plutôt plutôt difficile à gérer en ce
moment si elle est des regrets ni le
sort de son marasme viennent en ciel
signale que c'est c'est plus acceptable
de prendre un tel niveau de dette de
spéculer et le bonhomme est là pour vous
sauver donc c'est fort probable que
l'effet contagion trop important pour le
gouvernement intervenir mais en même
temps s'en verrait un signal qui est un
peu contradictoire avec ses actions
dernier mot et ce serait d'aider le
président de ce groupe e l'axé qui le
milliardaire soudja in 1 c'est un homme
important en chine ça
évidemment ça fait partie des hommes les
plus fortunés en chine qui vient d'une
famille assez modeste et pour avoir eu
l'occasion de rencontrer la compagnie à
plusieurs reprises ce dirigeant le
également s'éteint c'est évidemment
quelqu'un d'extrêmement ambitieux et qui
a fondé un empire donc oui en effet
c'est sa voix n'est pas que certaines
sources on sa fortune elle m'a fait
andré flageul merci beaucoup c'est très
clair on va sans doute vous rappeler si
jamais ça se détériore cette situation
merci à la prochaine un grand plaisir
merci roi pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit